someone there when I came to
but it wasn't a good Samaritan
[Music]
whatever was inside he passed it to me
you
hey youtubers is Charlie so they finally
did real Johnny Blaze stuff they kind of
teased him in last week's episode but
they full-on put him on screen so what
it sounds like based on the narration
here
Robby Reyes feels like Ghost Rider here
Johnny Blaze Ghost Rider past the spirit
of vengeance into him meaning that what
the TV show might have done is just
passed the mantle so for those of you
wondering where Danny ketch is they're
like how could he know skip over Danny
ketch well I think the fact that Robby
Ray has worked at a junkyard and we saw
that in the first couple of episodes was
an Easter Egg for that now for those
either don't know who Danny catches he
was the second version of Ghost Rider he
was kind of like an updated version of
the character when they felt like the
Johnny Blaze character had gotten kind
of stale so they introduced a new Ghost
Rider but he got his powers via a
talisman rather than making a deal with
Mephisto like Johnny Blaze did so while
I think there will be more Easter eggs
for Danny ketch I just think that
they're going from Johnny Blaze to Robby
ray is on the TV show and they've
changed a bunch about the backstory so
just to explain the difference when it
seems like they've done is they tried to
make the characters a little bit more
complex from the comic book origin story
of Robby Reyes but for the most part the
heroes in the villains of that storyline
are the same so not only did this
episode show you Johnny Blaze in the MCU
remember technically it's all connected
even if the movie characters never come
on the TV shows it's still connected so
Johnny Blaze is inside the MCU now but
he might not be Ghost Rider anymore
because it sounds like he passed the
mantle but for those of you that are
freaking out this is only being told
from Robby ray is's point of view so he
might not completely understand how it
works like he thinks this is the devil
but it's really just Johnny Blaze Johnny
Blaze is the one that made the deal with
Mephisto but I'm totally fine with the
version they're doing I mean it's really
only the beginning of the season there's
still so many more episodes I'm
expecting Ghost Rider to be around for
the entire year not just up to the
mid-season finale like they just kind of
introduced a new Big Bad at the end of
the episode that's kind of in line with
Robby raises comic
book story but there are some changes so
as we go along I'll try to do
ghostwriter videos kind of explaining
what's different from the comics but I
think everybody was pretty jazzed up to
see it like everyone's just happy that
Johnny Blaze is somewhere in the
universe so they can continue to use the
ghostwriter character however they want
but I think if they send him to the
Netflix universe they would still keep
the Robby Reyes version of the character
and they would just do more ghostwriter
mythos so there'd be more Johnny Blaze
Danny ketch stuff but that's all kind of
up in the air like he's busy on agents
of shield right now so after he's done
with you know whatever storyline they
use him for then I think he's free to go
to the Netflix universe because I don't
think they're gonna try and use him in
the movies anytime soon but you guys can
let me know what do you think Johnny
Blaze showing up on the TV show means
for Ghost Rider mythos stuff later this
season like do you think that he will
come back later in the story in the way
they played this you don't know how old
he is because they say back in the day I
thought that was kind of funny the way
they did back in the day like you're
supposed to assume that it's within the
past couple of years because Robbie's
brother doesn't look any different like
he looks the exact same age so it
couldn't have been that long ago so you
kind of have to wonder how old Johnny
Blaze is as of right now if he's still
alive but I think the reason they played
it so ambiguously
is so that they can leave themselves
some room for later in the season if
they want to bring him back or you know
they want to change something way down
the road like they're just leaving
themselves a little wiggle room when it
comes to Ghost Rider stuff like if they
think there's something really cool or
they get permission to use characters
that they couldn't use right now they
could always do it later the other
important thing is that because of the
election next week in the United States
it looks like agents of shield is going
to be on break but it's the same for the
flash pretty much every Tuesday night
show is going to be on break so I'll be
doing bonus videos for stuff so be sure
to subscribe to get everything but let
me know if Johnny Blaze was a important
part of Robbie Reza's comic book story
did you know did a lot of cool stuff
during that comic book run do you think
they'll bring him back way later this
season for like a ghostwriter team-up
where you have like multiple versions of
Ghost Rider I'm not expecting anything
too crazy but I was really surprised
that they were able to do Ghost Rider to
begin
it so you think all bets are off when it
comes to stuff they can and can't do I
think they have a lot more freedom this
year so get hype and speaking of cool
things that are happening now like
characters that you didn't think would
ever appear on TV Talia al Ghul is going
to appear on arrow as part of a new
storyline but they didn't say when she's
going to debut so I'm assuming it's
going to be some time after the
mid-season finale because now they're
working on episodes 9 and 10 meaning
that anybody they announced that they've
just cast is for future episodes so its
episodes after episode 10 so there is
some cool arrow stuff happening tonight
from the comics so I'll do a video for
that that'll either post like really
late tonight or early tomorrow so just
look out for that to where you guys wait
for that to post you can click here for
my non-spoilery Doctor Strange review
and you can click here to rewatch that
like longer Johnny Blaze scene from the
other episode thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight there are two types
of things in the universe